monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues
la grèce a récemment publié un rapport
préliminaire sur l'impact sanitaire de
la 5g s'appuyant sur des études
scientifiques déjà disponibles lagence
conclu pour l'heure à un manque
important voire à une absence de données
scientifiques sur les effets biologiques
et sanitaires potentiels de la 5g il
ressort en effet que deux inconnus
principales doivent être levés
la première découle de l'absence
d'études spécifiques aux bandes de
fréquences qui seront utilisés notamment
le 26 gertz la deuxième tient une des
spécificités de la 5g le ciblage du
signal sur les utilisateurs qui implique
un temps d'exposition cours des
personnes mais à des niveaux
d'exposition élevée des réponses à ces
deux questions pour être à la portée par
le rapport final de lens est prévue pour
le premier trimestre 2001 21
or la procédure d'attribution des
fréquences aux opérateurs se déroulera
très prochainement et les premiers
déploiements devraient avoir lieu cet
été
il est pourtant évident que le bond
technologique que constitue la 5g ne
sera accepté qu'au prix d'une
rationalisation du débat public
ce que ne permet pas le calendrier
actuel madame la ministre pourrait vous
réellement tenir compte des conclusions
du rapport de l'homme cesse à collecte
alors que les fréquences ont déjà été
attribuées aux opérateurs et que la 5g
aura commencé à être déployés je
rappelle enfin que les efforts de
rationalisation ne doivent pas seulement
porter sur le volet sanitaire mais aussi
sur son aspect environnemental
le président de l'ademe auditionné dans
le cadre de la mission d'information
relative à l'empreinte environnementale
du numérique que j'ai l'honneur de
présider ainsi déploré qu'aucune étude
d'impact environnemental sur le
déploiement de la 5g n'était est menée
madame la ministre
allez vous enfin à mener une évaluation
de l'impact environnemental de la 5g
toujours mercier